so while Google kills contracts that
help our nation's defenses opting
instead to help China's AI Amazon puts
America first despite getting flak from
sheltered employees who think national
security is for losers CEO Jeff Bezos
sticks to his guns here he is at a
conference on Monday we are gonna
continue to support the DoD and I think
we should I'm you know I it doesn't make
any sense to me sometimes one of the
jobs of a senior leadership team is to
make the right decision even when it's
unpopular and if if big tech companies
are gonna turn their back on the US
Department of Defense this country is
gonna be in trouble
good for him now compare that common
sense to Google's virtue signaling
cowardice first Google suspended its
contracts with our military when some
workers whined about it then they helped
China create a search engine that
censors criticisms of its leaders which
suits Google since they'll remove
anything that upsets them ask James
d'amour
apparently this tech Titan thinks it's
more evolved in the country it exploits
defense is so yesterday security is for
fascists plus they're terrified of the
activists in the company cafeteria
Google ignores their heroic predecessors
like Ford and Douglas Aircraft or tech
geniuses Alan Turing and Norbert Weiner
Turing helped invent modern computing
but also broke secret codes to beat the
Nazis mathematician Norbert calculated
rocket trajectories during the same war
even movie stars like Hedy Lamarr helped
out she came up with a guidance system
for American torpedoes top that Taylor
Swift these people didn't care about PR
they cared about a country's survival
but not Google they may be the greatest
a search engine on earth but the one
thing they'll never find is a spine
Morgan you're still in the Navy aren't
you I am I do not speak on behalf of the
Department of Defense but I am every
well you are now we've covered this
topic when Google we've done a few
segments on how Google basically opted
out of helping out on our drone program
which would have helped the drones be
more precise which would save lives
preventing collateral damage Google
pulled out of that which actually makes
our drones less safe and then Tom Rogan
did a really good piece
comparing Amazon to Google and we see
this what do you make of Google i
disgusted by their come this company
yeah I am incredibly frustrated when you
see what they're doing in China the
Chinese today have Muslims detained and
internment camps and detention camps
there and so I think we're in this
really interesting period for American
business and it actually ties into the
Saudi case in that American businesses
are saying what does it mean to be an
American business are we an American
business first and foremost are we
seeking profit overseas what does it
mean do we care about a country's human
right records should we continue to do
business in Saudi Arabia after this if
so where do you draw the line you know
where do you draw the line and doing
your company's business overseas and I
think that that's something that
American businesses need to ask for
themselves today and it's gonna be even
more crucial as the president ramps up
his escalation the trade escalation with
China over the next two years we're in
you know we're in a cold war with the
Chinese and American businesses need to
decide are they patriotic or the
international business is seeking profit
yeah and you could be both you know
Jesse you're kind of an expert with
Google you Google your name constantly
it seems to me that Google wants the
freedom the markets and the profits but
not not the responsibility that comes
with it we're admitting that safety
helps that happen yeah I mean think
about it everyone's based out west and
North Korea already at Sony and North
Korea and nuclear missiles there I mean
they're if they're gonna go launch
they're gonna go right into Seattle San
Francisco or Los Angeles the Chinese
very aggressive in the Navy situation
they're hacking us cyber warfare and
when you think about a terror attack out
there also could really just stop the
presses so you've set it up nicely
American military supremacy over the
last hundred years has been underwritten
by patriotic big tech executives at
Manhattan Project
gee
pS stealth technology missile defense
everything that you think about military
advancements it's because of people on
in the tech sector that put their
country ahead of everybody else and if
that collaboration between these
executives and the Department of Defense
doesn't last then Silicon Valley doesn't
last mm-hmm I get one I never heard
about Hedy Lamarr that blew me away I
mean those worried that's that's the
equivalent of like Taylor Swift you know
building an amazing drone program yeah
we even had baseball players who were
spies you know what amuses me about this
is Jeff Bezos is under attack by
President Trump most of the time be
price owns the Washington Polo and then
e and then Trump says oh the Postal
Service is getting ripped off by Amazon
is constant
now here's Jeff Bezos he comes out and
says America is a great country we have
to defend our country right and suddenly
I see oh the conservators now are
flocking in defense of Jeff Bezos how
interesting how convenient we can
actually say you're watching post is
biased but but but Bezos is a patriot
but let me just say so when his
employees say guess what we have a moral
issue in terms of the facial-recognition
stuff being used against people and it's
not only overseas but in terms of our
police departments at home what goes on
in terms of American rights I agree that
they have a right to speak out and speak
to the leadership of their company I
also agree that Jeff Bezos said when
Jeff Bezos says the senior leadership
sometimes has to make a decision it's
not popular but it's the right decision
and I think he made the right decision
but that's not to say that everybody who
has a moral issue is somehow a wimp or
unpatriotic that's not I disagree they
are unpatriotic and they're wimps Dana
gates closed Judy they're bending to a
few loud voices because they don't want
the PR nightmare Silicon Valley is in a
political and ethical minefield right
now because victory and war is
increasingly dependent not just on what
happens on the battlefield but what
happens in your military servers and
your cyber warfare capabilities and so
you yeah
they're gonna have to figure out who do
they want to help right they won't have
the bottom line are they willing to help
China on some of these things for
example you went to Google when it
started its phrase was don't meet you
know right okay well I'm pretty sure
what the Chinese are doing would be
classified as evil and it does they
can't see that Americans want to use
better technology to limit collateral
damage so that you aren't hurting
innocent civilians so that you can
target more precisely and you're going
after terrorists big tech is replace big
banks now has the one that politicians
can go after what's interesting for them
ways and I say it's in a minefield is
because each side Republicans and
Democrats are mad at the tech CEOs but
for different reasons right it's you
know what tech tech is now Wall Street
remember everybody hated Wall Street
yeah now Wall Street's are relevant
really what wow this you know you always
talk about AI artificial intelligence
taking over so I think but what would
Gregg say about killer robots being sent
to kill our enemies I don't know I would
love that
oh yeah that means fewer of our human
beings being killed but rather send a
robot what happens when we sell it to
the Saudis and suddenly Oh kill robots
in now I mean it's already happening
when you look at what's happening in
Yemen and and the bidding was up so it's
not I mean whether it's robotics or the
warfare that razing know has already
happened and also this can be applied to
almost any kind of technology all right